[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT: Kevin Kelly has
a great line about humans
and our symbiotic
relationship with technology.
He says, "We are the creators,
and we are the created."
Now, of course, this echoes this
notion of ontological design
in that everything that we
design is designing us back,
that we have been in
a cybernetic feedback
loop with our technologies since
the beginning of early hominids
playing with stone tools and
inscribing their interior world
onto clay tablets with
little glyphs of meaning.
The minute that we started
to extend our mindware out
into the world, we've been
turning the mind inside out.
Technology is our second
skin, our exoskeleton.
Literally, we are exteriorizing
our nervous system,
our "mindware," as
McKenna likes to say.
And we've been doing it forever.
This is the most natural
thing in the world.
it is what it means to be human.
Right?
Kevin Kelly's beautiful
example is-- the moment
we discovered fire--
and thus, cooking-- we
all of a sudden created
an external stomach that
could pre-digest our food
so that we could absorb
that many more nutrients
from every meal
and not waste all this time
eating raw food all day long
just to basically
stay nourished.
Instead, we're freeing
up cognitive real estate,
freeing the mind
for other endeavors.
So essentially, externalizing
our stomach through fire
turned this technology
into a part of us
beyond our skin tissue,
in whose feedback
loop and engagement
with that technology
opened up a new space for a
Cambrian explosion of mind.
Fire and cooking
essentially made us human.
But again, the larger metaphor
here, the larger message
here is that our symbiotic
relationships with these tools
actually is who we are.
Our mind is distributed between
brains, tools, technologies,
and environments.
This is who we are.
We are, as Andy Clark, says,
the "natural-born cyborg."
We are the creators,
but we are the created.
What we create is
creating us back.
The "foodback loop" is
the symbol of life--
not the DNA molecule.
The feedback loop-- the loop.
That's us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]